but will it happen when they're when we
all want it to happen you know I mean if
it happens in four years from now but it
doesn't have to happen in four years
here's my thing again Mr encano please
hear me out this is I mean just for
legacy for legacy and just for all also
money I think the big money is
if he has an account what if he knocks
out dillian white right what if they
they set him up with some boxer who's an
elite boxer not Tyson Fury and he goes
and wins a big fight and God you got to
remember and ganu is
265 ripped yeah I couldn't wait to
probably be at 265. canned hams for
fists yeah just giant just he's a
[__] specimen and the power is
extraordinary and if he's just punching
and not worrying about takedowns if one
of those look at look at Wilder Wilder
who's the greatest artist ever crazy
greatest he's one punch knockout artist
I I would say I mean there's you have
your George Foreman's and Mike Tyson are
the most beautiful combinations we've
ever seen in the heavyweight division
but Wilderness power blap did you see
his last fight it wasn't even moving
away moving away he hits this guy into
guys stiff he has proposed that one
Ortiz when he hit Ortiz in the forehead
pull that up pull up Wilder knocks out
Ortiz because he hit him and Ortiz is a
durable guy a tough guy and he had
Wilder and some trouble in that fight
and Wilder just blap yeah right in the
forehead yeah you can tell man that
snaps back and Ortiz's eyes are all
about he's like what the [__] just hit
me those are the things you can't train
that is God's gift to you and again it's
that long frame like yeah look at
another lean look at that oh my goodness
look at this watch this
here it goes again
bam
I mean look at it you know what the [__]
he's just like trying to put his mouth
his mouthpiece is in he's still trying
to find it his legs aren't moving he's
like wait a minute he's like what the
[__] look at this look at his creepy
he's like upset about it he's confused
Wilder Preposterous power but it just
goes to show you like there's levels
look at the chin of Tyson Fury Tyson
Fury the 12th round that first fight
drops it right hand left hook and even
does this like it's over like I got him
yeah I got him nope Rises
I remember watching that one live and I
couldn't believe it I was like oh that's
it he's done in my bedroom screaming
alone in my bedroom screaming oh my God
he's winning the 12th round because my
wife was in the other room like what the
[__] are you yelling at I'm like he's
winning the [__] 12th round this is
insane he almost gets killed he gets
back up and he wins
Plan B option if usig fight fails to
happen is in Gano oh wow wow well the
USIC fight's gonna happen it's the most
important fight in boxing I think that
fight is gigantic because you got uzik
who's you know beats Joshua twice and
the best movement in boxing and skillful
he's a heavyweight lomachenko yeah and
was the Cruiserweight Champion is an
undersized heavyweight and you got Tyson
who's as big a heavyweight as you're
ever going to be six nine long as [__]
crazy agile with back fat like that
picture right there I couldn't tell him
look at that picture hands were falling
down or go back to that picture Jimmy
the picture just showed the USIC the
backup fight that he's a backup Fighter
the one that you just had up if you look
the rolls of fat off his back yeah
it's insane Peak Peak male performance
you haven't fought the Gypsy King you're
crazy dude he's the [__] best dad's
out of his mind I love him I love that
guy War Tyson Fury versus Alexander osik
headed to Wembley in April huge boost to
British boxing fans what a [__] fight
that's gonna be my guy that's gonna be
amazing I just don't know if Lucy has
the size to deal with that guy
it's gonna be interesting to see he what
strategy he employs whether or not he
can avoid the big bombs and the reach
and the length so long but not the long
lean type that we're talking about oh no
no no no no no no no no no a little
different a little different I mean he
doesn't give a [__] what his body looks
like he's just a fighter is he still
you see sober is he not sober he's back
on the sauce now he just doesn't drink
in Camp yeah okay I mean I don't know if
he's sober I don't think he's sober he's
always well he's that's what I mean
that's why I'm asking I know he goes
back and forth on you know he's he's
right in the head and then he's not and
then you'll see him in a clip and he's
had you know 40.
well you know he's an inspirational
story I mean he really is I mean the guy
was like he he beats Vladimir uh
Klitschko he he becomes a heavyweight
champion and loses his [__] mind yeah
he's drinking constantly almost
committed suicide was driving his
Ferrari thinking about just [__]
driving off a cliff and then gets it
together and becomes a heavyweight
champion again and then wasn't fully all
the way back when he fought Wilder yeah
and then fights Wilder in the rematch
and then now he's [__] tuned up and
ready beats the brakes off a Wilder and
then the third fight Wilder catches him
with a bomb yeah that bomb that he
caught him where you see the fat Ripple
all the way down to his body any other
human any other human they're not
getting back up any other human nobody
punches like Wilder nobody because you
like like we talked it's just it's in
him it's not he's not doing something in
the gym with the trainer to get that
kind of power that's you were born with
that gift it's also being a gypsy and
being around that [__] Rough Tumble
brawling World his whole life his dad's
a fighter his brother's a fight
everyone's a fighter around them just
[__] Savages just in the bones in the
bones gypsy people man whenever he talks
about retiring I'm like not yet don't do
it I I think that if he does beat USIC
it's still possible because they're
gonna fight in April right unless ganu
decides to take a big money boxing fight
before that which I don't blame him for
doing
but God damn it if he beats usick that's
really the only compelling interesting
thing for him in that Division I mean
what else would be compelling the Joshua
fight not really not after the USIC
fights I mean unless Joshua comes back
because they're talking about Joshua
fighting Wilder right isn't that the
talk no they're talking about Ortiz
fighting Wilder right no Ruiz Andy Ruiz
right that's what they're talking about
so Andy Ruiz we're talking about him
fighting Wilder if that's look Wilder
versus in God it would be crazy yeah
that would be crazy how about that fight
I just think as long as he gets
something yeah I just wanted to get that
you're going to leave that contract on
the table I hope you get some big big
fights man because that was a big yeah
I mean they operated more money than any
heavyweight before but I think the
sticking point I'm talking out of school
here because I don't know just what I've
read
um the sticking point I think was that
he wanted to be able to go off and do
boxing yeah it's his credit
he's like hey Conor McGregor did it why
can't I do it yeah and I get it
yeah I get it
I get it but if I'm getting yeah
hundreds of million dollars a fight
right on the table it's hard to a
hundred million dollars in the Floyd
Mayweather fight yeah and that's the
generational wealth yeah like how do you
find but he locked out where the UFC
wanted to partner with that and make
that happen right that's where that
whole situation really and that's what
angano I guess wanted to and it's just
like man they probably did that one time
and we're like all right you know what
yeah that was a whole well it's also if
the boxer beats up the UFC fighter yeah
how many times you want to sign up for
that you can't get the boxer to fight
UFC yeah the thing is no one wants to do
that